i want to i want to show you guys i
think one of one of the most infuriating
but greatest examples of the failures of
the modern media and the left and it's
this clip that mythicist myth informed
milwaukee guys posted they said uh this
is from a couple days ago dennis prager
is mocked on bill maher when he
describes the now mainstream leftist
belief that men can menstruate this is
from november 2019. queer theory and
critical race theory ideology are so
radical and coherent one risks looking
crazy pointing them out i want to play
this uh
let me let me get the audio effects i
always do that i always have the audio
set to the wrong setting but let me get
this uh audio properly and then swing
live we're talking about degrees to say
that men can menstruate is a lie and
that is now that is what is said
wait wait wait wait wait
you've never heard it right okay check
it out folks check it out i think anyone
who says
not menstruate what's considered
transphobic i i missed this whole story
i did are you trying to tell me where
are you getting just google it can then
menstruate who is saying this you're
talking about very small
you're talking about a very small
percent of people who are actually
powerful mainstream corporate sources
like the daily beast that said july 12
2017 yes men can have periods and we
need to talk about them i know this is
an old story but it's coming up now with
all of the parental rights and education
bills and the fact that this narrative
has become so prominent this this
article was originally published
september 21st 2016 three years after a
major corporate publication that was
once part i believe of newsweek
published this ridiculous story
bill maher three years later still
didn't get the memo his audience laughs
these people do not listen to politics
they have no idea what's going on in
this country they don't read the news
but they all think they're smarter than
you that they all bust out laughing it
is just like the story i think it was
kierkegaard the clown comes on stage and
he says there's a fire backstage
everyone run and the old audience bursts
up laughing thinking it's a joke and so
becomes even more frantic and they laugh
even harder and he said i think that's
how the world will end yeah
seeing this
the reason why i want to highlight this
is because
if back then people like bill maher or
jon stewart who had been on hiatus i
suppose had actually paid attention
like people like dennis prager were
maybe
they wouldn't be dealing with the
insanity they're dealing with now with
the democrats fleeing the democratic
party four to one in pennsylvania the
congressional uh the generic
congressional ballot being
three almost four points up for
republicans
and the rest of us wouldn't have to well
you know i'll just put it this way they
they've done it to themselves you reap
what you sow at this point where i am is
there are two distinct moral universes
and theirs has nothing to do with me
because this is a perfect example of
when they gave up bill maher here's what
i tweeted has become lazy and sad jon
stewart as well it's crazy to me that
they don't do cursory research on topics
anymore jon stewart just absolutely
pathetic not a single google search you
can't do that yeah no this is something
that we see very often i remember back
when i first started making cartoons on
the internet in 2016 and when i was sort
of in a sphere of people who were
criticizing the left and the far left
the criticism we often received is that
we were just talking about a small niche
of leftists who basically only existed
on college campuses and were completely
out of their minds but these weren't
ideas that it really made much sense to
critique because they were never going
to enter the mainstream and we were more
or less wasting our time now that's
obviously been proven to be completely
false these very niche bizarre ideas end
up becoming mainstream very quickly and
part of the reason for that is because
the left always needs to find a new
cause it's not as if they move the
social dial and go all right we're done
we're satisfied we've achieved equality
now we're going to let you know we're
going to rest and have society exist as
it is they constantly need to push for
more and more and more yeah i think that
also the the poisoning of our our food
supply and water supply with like micro
plastics and birth control that's being
peed into the sewer systems like is
causing people to go towards this
transgender
state of being and so it's that also is
adding on to the to the rhetoric i think
that's a myth i think that's greatly
over exaggerated i want to see more
reasons because we didn't talk about it
we did talk about it i think uh social
manipulation ideological manipulation i
think the fact that you have some people
who are
the epitome of follower and they'll just
go along with whatever i mean how many
people watched that episode of bill
maher and laughed along with him
thinking he was the smart one in the
room when he was just dead wrong and
they follow along with that for years
and now these stories that were
published in the corporate press six
seven years ago are now in the forefront
in our schools now these are the parents
these liberal parents in loudoun county
who are now freaking out and voting
republican these suburban moms who are
starting to wake up and freak out
because they watch shows like that
so i think indoctrination manipulation
but pure laziness from bad leaders i'll
say
a little bit of defense of bill maher i
have a lot of criticism bill maher but
he uh prager came at him and kind of
blindsided him with that data and
neither of them knew could back it up
like um bill asked him can where'd you
get that data who said that and dennis
didn't have an answer he didn't say the
daily beast he should have quoted the
article if he's going to bring it up um
so i suppose i suppose the issue i had
was with with dennis is that he was
heated when he said it if he presented
it in a more calm demeanor it wouldn't
have elicited the same response well
sorry i don't mean to interrupt you no
no i was just going to say but yeah i
did a tweet on this and and it's very
clear that this pattern right we see
this all the time it starts with oh no
this isn't happening it's not a real
thing and then it goes to well maybe
it's here and there it's a few crazies
and then by the end of it oh well it's
good actually right and this is the most
predictable thing you can imagine three
years ago this was a right-wing
conspiracy now it's something that every
major corporation every major
educational institution and now even
the government is saying
this is the most predictable thing in
the world and the amazing thing about
this is that bill maher this will not
change his priors at all he will not
think for a moment i was wrong he did
this interview with i think it was ben
shapiro recently and he said you know
it's not me or the the i didn't change
the left change
it never occurs to him for a moment that
there is a reason that people keep
getting left behind by the left there is
a reason that this keeps occurring it's
a pattern it's predictable i've had i've
had people ask me to you know reach out
or people who are connected you know
saying like would you want to get in
touch with the people at bill maher and
i don't want to say too much about it
because it's not going to happen and i
wonder if i should try and extend an
olive branch in some capacity to talk to
the guy because he has said some good
things about how woke the left has
become but i'd be directly critical of
so much you know there was the uh ben
shapiro malcolm nance conversation yeah
and that was fantastic and ben is
correct i don't care about your opinions
on policy i care about if you're talking
about facts and when a conservative
comes out and says here's the thing that
is true and here's
evidence i say okay that's true then
they say here's my opinion on the policy
i say well that we can discuss
what's happening now is a conservative
like ben shapiro goes on daily goes on
uh uh
real time with bill maher and says here
are the facts and they go oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa
and it's like if you haven't done the
research bill how are you hosting this
show so so ian i i i accept your point
especially about dennis prager being
unable to say here's where it's
happening i think the issue for dennis
was it was three years beyond the point
of this of this conversation beginning
so the answer was actually every major
corporate website corporate news upset
has stated this in some form or another
he pulled a knee in crossland dennis
prager did he he did uh derailed the
conversation and then didn't know what
he was talking about he didn't back it
up and everyone thought he was an idiot
but he was right but here's what we do
and this is why i'm gonna say it right
now look i think bill maher's show is
just our it's it's just okay archaic
it's obsolete performance on this show
if someone comes on the show and says
it's a lie to say that you know men can
menstruate you know we do pull it out we
all have laptops
and and and the desktop terminal like
let's let's let's search in real time
it's remarkable to me that bill maher
still exists in this vacuum the show is
called real time
it's called real time can't take his
phone and i mean even dennis couldn't
applaud his phone and be like there you
go here let's search in real time do you
guys even read the news and you know
what i would have said when i started
laughing i'd take my phone up i'd pull
it up and i'd say there it is guys 2016
the daily beast let me get another
article you mean to tell me i'm the only
one on this panel who actually reads the
news then why do any of you think you
should have an opinion on news yeah and
also not to monday morning quarterback
prager here too much but i would have
asked her i like to think i would have
asked why is that wrong why is what i'm
saying incorrect do you not believe that
men can become women because this was a
mainstream view on the left and if
that's the case then why isn't it the
case that men can menstruate when dennis
prager goes on to say that college dorms
for for males have tampons uh bill mars
that's for their girlfriends
talk about
you take a guy like bill maher you know
what i think i think he retired
this is i think we see a lot of this i
think bill maher retired in his mind yep
mentally yeah yeah like he's like look
i've been doing this for decades i'm so
exhausted there's other things i want to
do i'm not going to read the news all
day just give me the give me the copy
i'll read it and we'll talk about
whatever politically incorrect was
badass and then he got after 9 11 it was
like some government clamp down there
like he's saying too much shut him down
and they shut his show down and i think
he changed after that he was like whoa i
got a self-censor now or i'm going to
not make it in the same time
well they put him on hbo and the idea
was that he didn't have to worry about
it and i used to watch this all the time
i used to watch a daily show all the
time and i will point this out every
time jon stewart praised project veritas
on more than one occasion that's great
now he's just woke
yelling at andrew sullivan and it's just
all of this stuff is the lowest of
lowbrow garbage my the reason i bring it
up here is because dennis prager was
correct on this prageru has been leading
the charge granted conservative ideology
i don't care they're correct when they
say the left has made the argument now
they give their counter argument you can
agree with them or disagree with them
but their premise is correct and people
like bill maher people like jon stewart
people like stephen colbert have
abandoned what they once were supposedly
representing which was reality yeah like
colbert said right reality has a liberal
bias
now it's fictional cult world has a
liberal bias and the rest of us are
confused as to what these people are
reading when they read anything if they
read anything and that's a really
important point one thing you mentioned
earlier is the fact that societies and
cultures have always had authority
structures and they've always had rules
that people are expected to follow but
part of what's so bizarre about this is
you basically have rules which are
wildly unpopular and historically
unprecedented that the left is forcing
on everyone else and it is even most
people on the left it's a very small
percentage of extremely online
individuals who will complain to
corporations and make them feel as if
they need to censor themselves and
change their corporate structuring and
advertising why what's wrong because
it's around 10 of the of the population
well it's increasing it it is absolutely
increasing and i think the idea is
spread but chances are when you
encounter someone who says a man can
become a woman they don't genuinely
believe that i'm not saying that
absolves them from saying it it's
actually an even bigger problem because
they are being dishonest but most people
recognize this stuff as ridiculous the
question is how do we make them feel
comfortable saying that when i was
talking to a friend of mine on facebook
i told the story before and she
all of a sudden started adopting the
gender ideology stance
she she told me
you know the whole uh she was like trans
women or women trans men or men and i
said okay i don't care if that's your
your premise my question to you then is
i asked her you would be
physically attracted to someone who's
biologically female like a person with a
vagina but who is like you know got a
beard and and she was like i could learn
how to do that and i was like that
sounds like conversion therapy to me and
she just blocked me yeah because like
it's it's because
there is
i i feel like
a lot of these people are not strong
moral leaders not everybody is i feel
like many of these people just want to
be followers because it's simpler and
the logic of their brains is conflicted
with the survival aspect of their brain
to fit in with society i must just say
this exactly well and that's that's
extremely insidious because ultimately
you either live what you believe or
believe what you live as they say and if
you stay silent about the truth for long
enough you do start to believe the lie
so i'm not saying that we're not at risk
of people buying into this we very
clearly are and my view is the exact
opposite we are in danger but oftentimes
conservatives are trying to convince
people on these issues what we need to
be doing is help people understand that
the thing that they already actually
secretly believe is not something that
they should be embarrassed or afraid to
say but here's the thing and you got to
remember this societies are run by
organized minorities every time so
saying that it's not everybody on the
left of course it's not yeah that's not
what matters what matters is who on the
left believes it and where they sit in
positions of power
there's a reason everyone is adopting
this stuff it's not because they
necessarily believe it right away but
eventually they do believe it i think
they do eventually genuinely take it on
board because they understand this
received morality is advantageous in our
society they know that and so that's why
people will do like tim was talking
about they will go out and they will
alter their beliefs system because the
people who are important are telling
them
what is going to come next what is going
to be signaled as positive what is going
to increase their standing and what's
going to make it easier for them to get
along along with what's actually going
to be moral and so saying oh just a few
people believe it or it's a small
minority
if it's the right minority that's the
most dangerous thing possible i wouldn't
disagree with any of that but what i
would reaffirm is my point that what we
have to do in order to combat that is
have people speak their minds and speak
the truth because it's only going to be
powerful if we acquiesce to it
i got this quote here uh darwin it's not
the strongest of the species that
survives nor the most intelligent is
that how it goes but it's the one that
is most adaptable to change
uh terrifying but true well uh have you
guys ever seen idiocracy yep mike judge
man talk about brilliant i love the
point made in the beginning eventually
evolution wasn't rewarding the strongest
or the smartest it was rewarding those
who simply reproduced the most
yeah as as as a species we have created
this sphere of safety
where we're untouched from war in the
united states for the most part in the
past what 200 years or 150 years or so
civil war obviously was bad uh we're on
we we do have crime but relative to the
rest of the world we have fat homeless
people i mean a serious problem in this
country and though we do have poverty we
are extremely wealthy uh extremely
wealthy extremely well-fed extremely
safe
and so this has created that environment
that mike judge was sort of talking
about evolution simply rewarding those
who reproduce the most but in this case
it's ideological reproduction exactly
yeah i mean it's just the ideas that
become the most popular that end up
governing your society now i'm very
optimistic in some sense i believe that
ultimately in the final final analysis
the truth wins but your society has no
guarantee of existing forever in in a
more like darwinist
previous iteration of our civilization
less technologically advanced
the strongest and the smartest would
survive by nature of their ideology
working together having strong families
having strong communities being armed
now everything's so safe the ideology
that's become becoming more powerful and
dominant is deconstructivist is
reductivist it's a blank slate it is
it's deconstruction yes it's breaking
everything apart now that can exist
because we're in such a magnificent
bubble of wealth and security until they
destroy it by deconstructing it
and then it's going to be just pure
chaos man like you know the food
shortages that are coming yes the the
product of electing someone like joe
biden out of sheer ignorance resulting
in the chaos that we've had over the
past year i am developing the probably
highly unpopular opinion and you're
welcome to pitch in on this if you think
along the same lines that we desperately
need some form of hardship to make us
realize that our imagined difficulties
are just that they're completely
imaginary we have much bigger things to
worry about we've just never had to
worry or even think about our survival
we don't know where our food comes from
that's a huge problem we're about to
learn that's troubling i think it's what
we need that's the amazing thing too
like
uh i visited farms
and growing up in the city it really was
a aha moment when i saw actual
production right because i mean illinois
has got farms you know but people don't
even can connect the dots of
the the wheat fields get you know uh
harvested and then sent to processing
and then it makes it way to a factory
and then gets turned into food the first
time i watched how it's made and they
were like cupcakes how they're made and
it shows like a guy pouring huge a
massive bag of flour this giant vat and
i'm just like
wow and then the machine like cranking
out the cupcakes and sealing the bags
how it's made it is amazing show how
it's made is an amazing show because
people don't don't recognize supply
chain you go to the store boom cupcakes
in a wrapper you got no idea how they
got there they grew there yep just blink
there it is
it's interesting if you went to the
store and on every piece of food you're
going to buy there was a little video
under it that was showing you the entire
manufacturing process of the piece sorry
interrupted oh no bro no so uh
machiavelli talked about ruling uh rule
of foxes and rules rule of lions right
and your foxes are you're very clever uh
quick-witted they're gonna be kind of
your liberals they're gonna be the
people who are good at combining and
coming up with new ideas and then your
lions are going to be kind of your more
conservative patriotic martial type
people and he said at the beginning your
civilizations are always run by lions
because they have to secure safety you
have to make sure you're getting food
supply those kind of things but over
time as your society gets more complex
you start to see the rise of the foxes
because they're able to address these
new things these new problems that are
coming up they're able to make these new
combinations and synthesize things but
as your society gets more decadent as
you get further away from the problems
that the lions solve you forget why you
had lines in the first place and your
fox has become the dominant ruling class
and we are so far around the bend we are
all foxes right everyone in charge right
now is a college grad they've never been
in the military they've never farmed
they don't know anything about this
stuff
food shows up at their table truck
drivers bring it to them they never give
it a second thought
of course the world's safe we're america
we can conquer anything and so they
don't think about what happens when you
can no longer just work your way out of
this by being clever what happens when
the rubber meets the road and you know
what uh lions do
lines sleep
they sleep most of the day
lionesses i guess are out to go on
actually work but the male lions just
just sleep and it kind of feels like
that's what it is the foxes have started
conniving started scheming and taking
things while the lion looks around and
he's like
hey simba
all that the sun touches is ours yeah
i'm going to bed yep and then the foxes
run in and just start controlling
everything and the lions don't pay
attention they sleep to conserve their
energy for the hunt or something no they
just they just sleep it's knocked out
the lionesses do the hunting yeah yeah
the dudes basically get up eat bang and
go to sleep so kamala harris she's the
lioness in this equation i don't know
she's probably the hyena
yeah if we're doing lime king she's
definitely
is it too far gone
i think the system's gonna have to go
through them through some serious hard
times and probably a little bit of
collapse before people realize the issue
i i think that we've been trained to
believe that experts are the key right
you gotta have an expert for everything
you need to have a person who has a
particular degree and has enough
doctorates enough credentials and
they're the ones that solve everything
everything is solvable through like this
kind of managerial scientific yo system
but it's not and at the end of the day
you there are certain things that have
to be done physically in the real world
it's not just always ideas that solve
these problems and i think until people
taste some of the difficulty that comes
from society that's entirely based on
kind of fox governors they're never
gonna realize the problem thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you